oui bonjour c'est le livreur
un colis de 12 par 7
tiens mais c'est gouttes tu vas voir
elle permet de voir à travers les
vêtements
mais ça me dégoûte quoi c'est
bon en même temps j'ai un peu mal aux
yeux non mais le Pollet l'écran tout ça
c'est manque de sommeil
qu'est-ce que c'est que cette merde
[Musique]
c'est malin avec Agathe je vous ai même
pas parlé du sponsor de cette vidéo le
magazine Ciel et Espace qui me fait une
nouvelle fois l'honneur de mon
sponsoriser cette vidéo c'est le
deuxième point qui me font confiance et
c'est un vrai plaisir de vous présenter
à nouveau ce magazine qui m'a tant fait
rêver depuis tout à l'heure le numéro de
ce mois-ci qui est sur deux mois le
numéro de ce mois-ci je sais pas comment
on dit ton sacre tout un dossier à mon
chouchou des chouchous le James web et
c'est alors comme d'hab vous allez
retrouver toute
l'actuelle et espace en même temps c'est
marqué dessus les brèves les futurs
projets des interviews le truc est
vraiment rédigé par des passionnés qui
prennent le temps de l'info on n'est pas
dans l'instantané du scoop là vous êtes
sûr au moins de ce que vous allez dire
alors bien entendu en tant que c'est
mignon aux abonnés à cette chaîne vous
êtes des gens de goût à qui ce magazine
va parler personnellement mais également
c'est une super idée cadeau pour les
impies qui ne sont pas encore abonnés à
cette chaîne et au lieu d'une énième
merde en plastique un abonnement au
magazine c'est vraiment génial pour les
gamins ou pour vos parents qui viennent
de partir à la retraite ou pas
d'ailleurs
en fait c'est pour tout le monde voilà
en tout cas voilà moi quand j'étais
gamin c'est vraiment quand on m'a offert
un abonnement un magazine de sciences et
que j'ai commencé à lire notamment si
elle espace que ça m'a vraiment donné la
vocation et ça tombe très bien puisque
j'ai des offres spéciales pour vous vous
pouvez bénéficier d'une réduction
exceptionnelle de 20% sur un abonnement
de papier un an c'est si numéro + 2
hors-série plus un annuelle 2 ans c'est
la même chose mais pas en double
pécuniairement parlant comme je suis
payé la commission avec eux en vrai ça
m'arrange carrément que vous preniez
l'abonnement 2 ans vous avez des
podcasts exclusifs et un club abonnés
avec des avantages spéciaux avec le code
le point Genius 20 et je monte même
jusqu'à 30% de réduction sur
l'abonnement Premium avec le code le
point Genius 30 avec accès à tous les
podcasts et les anciens numéros du
magazine en numérique il y a une promové
en description bien entendu faites-moi
péter les stats
non non mais j'ai vraiment mal aux yeux
on a vu dans la précédente vidéo en
fichier en description comment on a pu
calculer la vitesse de la lumière à
l'aide de beaucoup d'ingéniosité et
d'outils aussi rudimentaires que géniaux
mais avant de continuer dans la
narration de cette folle épopée je
voulais faire un petit détour une
incartade vers une des applications de
la lumière les plus ouf les plus
inspirantes et avec une histoire tout
aussi voire plus passionnante le laser
on en a déjà parlé à plusieurs reprises
je vous ai fait une playlist entière sur
la lumière il est prévu pour le moment
encore trois vidéos dessus mais
n'hésitez pas à me dire dans les
commentaires si vous avez d'autres idées
sur le sujet des trucs un petit peu
insolites à traiter je suis preneur
aujourd'hui le laser est partout autour
de nous comme le génie et même si les
différents de ceux qu'on est habitué à
voir en fiction les usages du laser sont
incroyablement variés du plus bois la
découpe laser chez les fabricants de
custom à la médecine la lecture de CD
DVD est Blu-ray dans la construction la
télécommunication la douchette à code
barre du supermarché le truc pour rendre
fou ses comptes de chat ou chez les
extrémistes et tout ça ça vient de la
prédiction d'un certain
comment ça se passe et oui tout comme
l'intrication quantique les trous noirs
ou le boson de Higgs le laser a été
théorisé bien avant qu'on arrive à le
fabriquer ou à l'observer parce que déjà
un laser c'est quoi ou plutôt c'est quoi
pas c'est pas quoi qu'est-ce que c'est
pas c'est pas ça c'est pas ça et c'est
pas ça ça c'est une créature c'est pas
un phénomène optique encore que quand on
voit sa tronche on demande de quand même
s'il y a pas un phénomène optique
derrière mais donc non c'est pas ça
c'est pas un truc qu'on voit sauf
impureté dans l'air qui va disperser les
rayons pas sinon on le voit juste à
l'endroit à l'impact donc quand tu te
brûles les yeux et c'est un pas un truc
qui fait du bruit voilà c'est c'est de
la lumière c'est vrai que de la lumière
qui fait du bruit ça s'est jamais vu
bref Jojo ta merder sur toute la ligne
laser est un acronyme pour light
amplification va estime le ited émission
of Ready et c'est carrément cool comme
nom on a de la chance que ce soit un
Américain qui l'ait trouvé non parce que
bon ça m'était découvert par un Français
par exemple bon bah le truc ce serait
appelé alter déjà c'est moins classe
ça accroche un petit peu plus mais pire
ce truc avait été découvert par Nicolas
Tesla mais on aurait appelé ça
ou si ça avait été un biélorus un ou par
un mongole on aurait appelé ça à un
taigo
non c'est pas mal ça tu es Hugo en fait
non non je trouve ça chante bien donc
voilà laser c'est classe en américain et
mongole le reste de la saloperie mais
alors c'est quoi une émission stimulée
de rayonnement pour émettre de la
lumière sur le principe c'est assez
simple on va apporter de l'énergie à un
atome et bim ça fait de la lumière voilà
c'est tout pour moi abonne-toi la cloche
tout ça c'est quand même dommage qui est
pas un prix Nobel de la vulgarisation
plus précisément pour comprendre laser
il faut déjà comprendre comment était
mise la lumière normale un atome c'est
un noyau constitué de protons et
neutrons ça on a l'habitude de le voir
sur la chaîne avec le nucléaire mais on
passe en occuper aujourd'hui et
d'électrons qui orbite sous forme de
couches électronique si vous avez fait
de la chimie au lycée vous souvenez on a
un nombre précis d'électrons par couche
et tout le monde est à sa place avec un
niveau d'énergie définie mais on va
pouvoir apporter de l'énergie à cet
atome donc en faisant ça on va exciter
l'électron qui va sauter à une couche
supérieure sauf que lui il a rien à
et comme nous quand on est excité
bah il va finir par se désexciter et
rentrer chez lui et en faisant ça il va
y mettre un photon oui on lui a apporté
de l'énergie il faut donc il la rende un
moment et ça se passe donc sous forme de
lumière que là c'est bon pour tout le
monde
de toute façon pour pas me répondre donc
je continue le problème pour la lumière
normale c'est que par défaut les photons
vont être émises dans toutes les
directions et dans toutes les longueurs
d'ongles ah oui c'est longueur d'onde la
lumière est une onde électromagnétique
et comme toutes les ondes elles forment
une sorte de vague schématisée comme ça
et selon la longueur cette onde va avoir
des propriétés et dans une certaine
plage des couleurs différentes selon la
longueur d'onde va donc avoir des ondes
radio des micro-ondes des infrarouges de
la lumière visible du rouge au violet de
l'ultraviolet des rayons X et des rayons
gavas vous vous souvenez on l'a déjà vu
plein de fois dans l'épisode sur la
radio notamment dans celui sur le
micro-ondes ou dans ce sur la
radioactivité la lumière visible est
contenue dans une toute petite plage
entre 400 et 800 nanomètres c'est comme
le son voilà quand on change la longueur
d'onde on a un son plus ou moins grave
et si on a plein de photons qui possède
toutes ces longueurs d'ondes ça nous
donne un mélange de toutes ces couleurs
de la lumière blanche
bien le laser maintenant qu'est-ce qu'il
a de si particulier par rapport à la
lumière normale pour la lumière normale
donc l'électron reçoit de l'énergie il
s'excite puisse des excite en émettant
un photon et il se barre rien à carrer
d’attendre le copain et le processus
recommence à zéro mais le laser lui va
utiliser une propriété mise en évidence
par notre bon vieux BBR l'amplification
par émission stimulée de rayonnement
cette fois au lieu d'avoir une ampoule à
écrire en tour on va créer un système
qui va empêcher la lumière de se barrer
dans toutes les directions donc quand un
photon est émis cette fois-ci il risque
de rencontrer un autre atome et surtout
de rencontrer un autre atome déjà excité
avec un électron bien chaud patate en
train de faire la bamboche chez les
voisins du dessus et c'est là que la
magie opère si un électron déjà excité
capte un photon déjà émis et donc
exactement à la bonne énergie un
deuxième photon va alors se créer un
photon parfaitement identique allant
dans la même direction et avec la même
fréquence c'est l'émission stimulée et
ces deux photons vont à leur tour
rencontrer d'autres atomes et ainsi de
suite augmentant de manière
exponentielle le nombre de photons qui
vont pouvoir sortir du système
parfaitement aligné et de manière
parfaitement homogène on a donc un
pinceau de lumière des photons quasiment
parallèles ce qui va permettre de
concentrer sa puissance pour découper du
métal par exemple ou lire les pistes
très fines décédées et Blu-ray ou de
brûler le bulbe d'un poil et chaque
atome va réagir à une énergie propre et
ainsi générer des photons avec une
certaine longueur d'onde d'une certaine
couleur donc et plus la longueur d'onde
va être fine plus on pourra lire des
informations petites le CD se faisait
initialement avec un rayon rouge
d'environ 700 nanomètres les Blu-ray on
est autour de 480 nanomètres et là où la
lumière classique va émettre une plage
très large y compris dans des couleurs
invisibles notamment l'infrarouge
invisible à l’œil nu bien entendu la
plage d'un laser elle va être de
quelques millièmes de nanomètres c'est à
dire que tous les photons vont avoir
vraiment quasiment la même fréquence
même une LED colorée va émettre des
photons sur une plage de dynamomètre par
exemple mais alors comment la découverte
dans les années 1910 beber bricole ses
petites manigances dans son coin et
découvre de manière mathématique qu'a
priori si on excite un atome d'une
certaine manière avec une certaine
énergie cet atome va alors émettre un
photon bien spécifique les applications
de cette semble folle et donc la
communauté scientifique dans son
ensemble sans car l'oignon absolument
total voilà en mode balek et les gars je
viens de découvrir une super propriété
était la lumière tout le monde s'en
branle moi le premier donc et à part
pour quelques cakes du département
physique quantique le truc est rangé
pendant plus de 40 ans ou placard des
idées bien mais pas top faut dire que si
aujourd'hui on trouve des lasers partout
pour 3,5 ans
au début c'était vraiment pas gagné
c'est bien beau de chercher à prouver
une théorie en fabriquant des machins
mais si on sait pas à quoi il sert au
final il y a pas grand intérêt ça
mobilise pas les foules mais bon dans le
taille il y a toujours une poignée
d'énerver qui vont consacrer leur vie à
ça donc ok Einstein a dit dans certaines
conditions précises la physique prévoit
que pour un photon absorbé il en
ressorte deux identiques mais c'est quoi
ces conditions comment on les obtient un
physicien américain de la Colombia
University de New York du don de Charles
towns connaît parfaitement la théorie
comme il le fait régulièrement ou pas
d'ailleurs sa biographie n'est pas
suffisamment précise sur le sujet il
pose son cul sur un banc à filer des
coups de pied au pigeon lire son journal
ou boire son café peu importe c'est la
partie banc qui est importante il est
donc la pépouse à ce gelée meule sur son
banc à la con et là il a une idée il se
dit qu'il va pouvoir créer un système
stimuler à l'aide de micro-ondes et il
appelle ça Mever
amplification by stimulating émission of
rageation ses collègues se foutent de sa
gueule pas parce qu'il a un accent de
merde parce que lui il est américain
donc il arrive à dire ce de mot
de regation et il paraît qu'il n'y
arrivera pas super les collègues mais en
1954 il produit le premier flux de
lumière avec une longueur d'onde très
pure le système encore utilisé
aujourd'hui dans le principe est
constitué d'une chambre qu'on appelle la
charge d'Atom c'est ça qu'on va venir
exciter ça peut être solide liquide ou
gazeux peu importe lui towns c'était de
l'ammoniaque gazeux d'un dispositif pour
envoyer de l'énergie il va nous atomes
ça peut être des photons ou des
électrons et un système optique avec des
miroirs et une cavité optique un trou
d'où la lumière amplifié et stimuler
tout ça va pouvoir sortir la lumière va
donc pouvoir rebondir d'un miroir à
l'autre pour augmenter l'amplification
et assez curieusement thanks n'est pas
le seul à réussir l'exploit puisque dans
exactement le même temps Alex leur
propre et Nicolas et Basov de l'Institut
de Physique de l'bdf à Moscou arrivent
exactement la même conclusion que
l'Américain et du coup sympa le comité
de novel leur accordera le prix de
physique à tous les trois en 1964 par
contre c'est sympa leur petit gadget
mais c'est toujours pas un laser les
micro-ondes ont une longueur d'onde bien
plus élevée que la lumière visible et le
défi pour arriver à avoir un laser de
nos propres yeux et tout aussi dur à
relever parce que oui théoriquement un
laser pourrait faire fondre du métal
mais pas avec des micro-ondes pas assez
énergétiques mais déjà le fait d'avoir
prouvé que c'était possible ça ouvre
plein de possibilités et de champs
d'application de la télécommunication à
la fusion nucléaire donc tous les labos
et l'armée bien entendu un se lance dans
le développement d'un majeur optique un
majeur dans la lumière visible donc
Mazet ou majeur Mazères du coup puissant
pour les lasers en 1958 Tence décrit le
mécanisme nécessaire pour sa conception
sans pour autant réussir à le fabriquer
mais dans sa course arrive également en
1957 un certain Gordon Gould soit un an
plus tôt que towns c'est lui qui propose
de remplacer mycorhef par light dans
l'acronyme et le mazaire devient le
laser sauf que Gould il a juste trouvé
le nom lui enfin il a aussi développé
deux trois théories plutôt solides quand
même à côté mais il a pas créé quoi que
ce soit de palpable et au moment de
déposer son brevet je sais pas ce qu'il
a branlé une virgule que j'ai une case
j'en sais rien ben le truc qui lui
refusé voilà et donc la paternité du
merdier lui passe sous le Zen Gould va
alors tenter d'avoir raison par la voix
judiciaire et par bosser en parallèle
pour l'armée qui lui offre des millions
pour faire ses recherches mais l'armée
découvre que le mec était pas totalement
insensible aux charmes des cocos et bien
entendu il se fait virer les labos se
tient la bourre de tous les côtés pour
réussir à être le premier à créer un
laser donc quand un gars sorti de nulle
part finit la course en tête sans que
personne ne le soupçonne Théodore myman
a 28 ans en 1955 le mec bosse pour une
boîte qui croit pas du tout à son projet
qui diffère carrément de ce que
développe tous les autres mais après un
peu de chantage c'est boss se finissent
par lui filer une petite enveloppe et
quelques mois pour réussir son pari
avant de lui demander de fermer sa
mouille définitivement et de suivre les
ordres de la boîte parce que le teddy là
il se dit que quand même le rubis ça
serait un super matér iau qu'est-ce
qu'on connaît qui est suffisamment calé
en caillou qui pourrait nous expliquer
ça bah
sans aucun
autre
merci pour ton invitation mais je t'ai
pas invité pour bien comprendre le mieux
c'est que je passe directement chez toi
en fait bouge pas mais non non on n'a
pas le temps elle est partie
Valentine mais elle est vraiment
partie en fait
qu'est-ce que qu'est-ce qu'on fait du
coup on l'attend
répondeur
tu as raison c'est beaucoup trop long en
fait oui un rubis c'est un joli caillou
et c'est pour ça que c'est cool
alors pourquoi du rubis dans le laser
parce qu'il est fluorescent mon bon
petit pH si tu lui mets un projecteur
dans la moule façon garde à vue il va
t'éternuer des photons au visage en plus
il a une très longue durée de
fluorescence d'environ 3 millièmes de
seconde oui c'est beaucoup ça veut dire
pif garde à vue et 3 millisecondes pouf
éternuement de photons vous l'aurez
compris ce type de laser produit une
lumière non pas continue mais pulsé
comme ceci
mais ce qui est intéressant avec notre
rubis et non pas notre rugby c'est qu'il
a des bandes d'absorption large c'est à
dire qu'il est capable d'intercepter et
d'absorber une large gamme de photons
vers le vert et le bleu qui sont parmi
les photos les plus énergétiques dans le
spectre visible donc ça nous arrange
bien et entre parenthèses c'est
d'ailleurs pour ça qu'il est rouge notre
minéral parce qu'il absorbe le bleu et
le vert mais sa particularité comme on
l'a dit c'est qu'il garde pas cette
énergie pour lui il nous la Redonne
derrière grâce à la fluorescence alors
pour résumer pif garde à vue en lumière
blanche les atomes du rubis absorbent le
bleu et le vert leurs électrons en sont
tout chauds et pas physimède des photons
à leur tour mais pas n'importe quelle
photo des photos à 694,3 nanomètres
précisément dans le rouge profond
couleur rubis comme de par hasard c'est
pour ça que la couleur du rubis est
civile est si lumineuse c'est qu'en plus
d'être rouge il nous fluorait aussi du
rouge par dessus l'épaule revenons-en à
notre laser l'important ici c'est que
nos atomes en se désaxant génèrent un
pic plus intense et beaucoup plus étroit
en bref le rubis et non pas le pubis va
permettre de concentrer le flux lumineux
c'est à dire que le rubis converti
faisceau lumineux de moyenne intensité
et de larges Games de longueur d'onde en
un faisceau monochrome rouge de haute
intensité et maintenant en termes que Ph
peut comprendre le cristal absorbe plein
de photons forts en chocolat et paf ça
fait un tout petit pic d'émission très
très intense mais ça ça marche surtout
avec des rubis artificiels parce que les
naturels sont bourrés d'impuretés et
d'erreurs dans leur structure
cristalline c'est pas un milieu optimal
pour nos expériences du tout alors quand
labo on peut les faire pousser en
contrôlant tous les paramètres ça nous
permet d'obtenir au contraire un solide
pur et homogène et on peut même doser la
quantité de chrome qu'on y colle oui
parce que le rubis c'est du corindon
avec du chrome dedans et si j'ai bien
tout compris c'est justement ces atomes
de chrome qui nous éternuent au visage
avant de te rendre l'antenne j'en
profite juste pour remercier le gang de
géologue qui m'ont aidé à comprendre
cette histoire parce que c'était velu
donc merci Vincent Renaud et Nicolas et
bien merci Valentine pour cette
éclairage très instructif mais de rien
mon bon pH du coup je peux oh là là
merci point trop d'enfant donc voilà le
rubis c'est génial sauf qu'à l'époque
les papiers qui sortent sur le sujet
disent que c'est pourri comme idée qu'il
faut du gaz et rien d'autre sauf qu'en
reprenant de calcul mais human se rend
compte que c'est de la merde et il reste
sur son idée de rubis tous les labos
sont donc à fond sur le gaz et neiman
débarquent un matin de juillet 1960
est-ce que ça m'a sans vouloir vous
commander
c'est bon et j'ai trouvé vous pouvez
arrêter j'ai mon laser à lumière visible
à base de rubis sauf que le gars annonça
à la presse et ce point avec un truc qui
fonctionne
moyenne pas du tout assez puissant du
moins pour que le personne arrive à
avoir le rayon donc personne n'y croit
sa publication dans un journal officiel
a même été refusé le préposé n'a même
pas pris le temps de la lire pensant que
c'était la même chose que ce qu'il avait
publié quelques jours avant mais
l'article est finalement publié dans la
revue Nature en août 1960 attribuant
définitivement la paternité à mayman ça
reste clairement imperfectionner mais il
a prouvé que c'était faisable et à
partir de là tout le monde se lance
réellement dedans sauf que vous avez pas
oublié Gordon Gould lui il entend pas se
faire dépossédés de son bébé comme ça
donc il multiplie les recours en justice
il a juste déposé un brevet de travioles
mais il considère que c'est quand même
valable et au bout de 20 ans
d'acharnement de milliers de marque
laqué en frites justice elle finit par
lui donner raison et donc maintenant 20
ans plus tard toutes les boîtes qui
fabriquent des lasers en utilisant plus
ou moins ses découvertes et elles sont
plus que nombreuses en 1980 doivent lui
filer des droits et c'est le pactole
pour Gordon en parlant de pognon comme
vous voulez peut-être vu passer YouTube
ferme ses portes définitivement et c'est
donc une bonne partie de mes revenus
qu'il faut le camp en effet comme je
l'ai déjà mentionné à plusieurs reprises
je ne touche plus directement les pubs
de YouTube cet argent va dans ma boîte
et sert donc à financer la chaîne en
terme de matos de production etc mais je
me verse pas de salaire directement
dessus je touche absolument zéro
là-dessus et donc actuellement mais
seule chose de revenus sont donc les
sponsors et vos dons une partie d'entre
vous qui était sur Youtube et donc
passer sur tipee spontanément et pour
l'instant je ne perds que 150 200 euros
de revenus à peu près j'ai prévu de
créer également une seconde page
qu'est-ce qui se bang en plus de mon
tipi mais je vous en reparle dans 15
jours et donc en attendant si vous
voulez soutenir la chaîne comme vous le
faisiez déjà peut-être sur Youtube ou
comme vous envisagiez peut-être de
sauter le pas la page tipee est en
description pour pouvoir me soutenir le
laser fait vraiment partie des
inventions fondamentales du XXème siècle
pour les télécommunications les horloges
atomiques et donc le GPS qui nous sont
devenus indispensables ou pour des
projets expérimentaux comme les futurs
centrales à fusion on y revient très
vite c'était pour ça aussi le laser
comme intro ou pour des trucs de loisirs
comme la lecture de CD de Blu-ray et où
l'épilation les différents lasers sont
aujourd'hui générés à partir du milieu
très différents gaz liquide solide et
sans le laser notre monde serait
vraiment très différent si encore une
fois la prédiction a précédé de
plusieurs décennies l'observation et la
réalisation cette trouvaille a pu voir
le jour grâce à l'acharnement d'une
poignée de curieux et de visionnaires
acharné qui ne voulait pas qu'on leur
dise que c'était impossible
le génie est partout
[Musique]